As more and more people around the world go
into self-isolation and quarantine due to
the ongoing coronavirus outbreak, there has
been an understandable surge in interest in
pandemic movies.
There have been a few good ones over the years,
like the '90s disaster flick Outbreak and
the intelligent take on the zombie genre 28
Days Later, but few seem to be capturing the
public's attention right now quite as much
as Steven Soderbergh's 2011 horrifying ensemble
thriller Contagion.
"I think I'm sick."
"What?
What's going on?
What kind of symptoms do you have?"
"Can't swallow.
Severe headache."
Believe it or not, the movie is #2 on iTunes'
rental charts, as of the making of this video,
only bested by Star Wars: The Rise of Skywalker.
Not bad for a movie that came out almost a
decade ago.
For many, the draw to Contagion as their viral-outbreak
movie du jour likely has a lot to do with
how realistic the film set out to be.
Instead of delivering outlandish Hollywood
thrills, screenwriter Scott Z. Burns wanted
to create a realistic film that drew from
the experiences of actual people who dealt
with pandemics.
Burns interviewed epidemiologists, virologists,
and other experts in an attempt to create
a fictional plague that would feel true to
life.
We can safely say that he did a terrifyingly
good job.
Given how close to reality Contagion often
feels, there's a lot of interest in how this
fictional worldwide outbreak comes to an end.
So let's take a look at how Soderbergh's film
concludes.
Contagion begins on day two of a global pandemic
caused by a fictional viral infection eventually
dubbed MEV-1.
The event of the film kick off when Minneapolis-based
business executive Beth travels to Hong Kong
and Macau for work and becomes infected with
the novel virus before traveling back to the
U.S.
After Beth dies of the illness and her son
passes a few days later, there are already
dozens of other MEV-1 cases around the world.
By the time scientists realize what's going
on, it has already spread out of control.
The ensemble film primarily focuses on the
doctors and scientists working to understand
and contain the viral outbreak.
Doctors Ellis Cheever and Ally Hextall of
the Centers for Disease Control attempt to
reduce the spread of MEV-1 within the U.S.
and work to develop a vaccine, while Dr. Leonora
Orantes of the World Health Organization travels
to Hong Kong in an attempt to track down the
origins of the virus and learn how it was
able to spread out from southeast Asia and
infect the rest of the world.
After tracking Beth's movements during her
trip to Asia, Dr. Orantes is able to determine
on day 14 of the pandemic that Beth was not
only patient zero of the outbreak in the U.S.,
but also of the virus itself.
However, at the CDC, the novel nature of the
virus has made it difficult to study.
By day 21, Dr. Hextall sees evidence that
the virus is mutating and becoming even more
deadly.
Riots over medication, looted grocery stores,
and empty, trash-filled streets have become
the norm, and Dr. Hextall races against the
clock to unlock the code to a vaccine that
will effectively stop the virus without first
killing the host.
"If we even had a viable vaccine right now,
we would still have to do human trials, and
that would take weeks."
Finally, on day 29, she cracks it and develops
a working vaccine.
In order to fast-track availability of her
new vaccine, Dr. Hextall conducts the first
human test on herself injecting it into her
own leg before going to visit her father,
who is infected with MEV-1, in the hospital
to test its effectiveness.
With a vaccine developed, the MEV-1 outbreak
begins to wane on day 135.
Dr. Cheever declares Dr. Hextall a hero, but
she rejects the label and the spotlight that
it would bring.
Instead, we see Dr. Hextall triumphantly placing
a sample of her vaccine in cold storage along
with the vaccines for SARS and H1N1.
In the final scene of Contagion, we get a
flashback that solves the mystery of how the
virus originated.
Earlier in the film, Dr. Hextall notes that
the MEV-1 virus contains strains of both bat
and pig DNA, and in the flashback, we see
a colony of bats disturbed from a tree that's
being bulldozed by a truck from the very company
that Beth worked for.
Later, one of the bats drops a piece of banana,
which came in contact with the virus, in a
nearby pig farm.
A pig eats the piece of banana, and is later
sold and butchered.
We later see the pig being prepared in the
kitchen of a fancy casino in Macau.
After handling the infected animal, the chef
is summoned away from his work.
He heads out of the kitchen without washing
up and poses for a photo with Beth.
This, we learn, was day one.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.